The book, which was Lee’s first and only
published novel until recently, was heralded
as an “instant classic” when it was published
in 1960, and it is a staple in high school
classrooms today.
But it might not exist at all if it hadn’t
been for a kind benefactor who helped to support
Harper Lee while she wrote the story.
Lee knew that she wanted to be a writer after
developing an interest in English literature
in high school.
After graduation, she attended Huntingdon
College in Montgomery, Alabama, where she
focused on writing.
However, a transfer to the University of Alabama
saw a switch to a law degree—no doubt in
an attempt to do something that was potentially
more lucrative—before turning her sights
back on writing again.
She wrote for the school paper before she
dropped out of college entirely, opting instead
to move to New York to pursue a career in
writing.
The problem is, you can’t produce a best-selling
novel overnight, and you have to eat somehow.
Lee ended up taking a job as an airline ticket
agent, where she worked for several years.
She was struggling with something all budding
authors find difficult to balance: having
the time and energy to write and the money
to support herself while doing so.
Luckily for Lee, she had befriended Michael
and Joy Brown.
Michael was a popular composer and lyricist
who worked on Broadway, and was quite well
off financially.
For Christmas in 1956, the couple gave Lee
a generous present: a year’s worth of wages.
With the money came a note saying, “You
have one year off from your job to write whatever
you please.
Merry Christmas.”
Who could say no to that?
Lee quit her day job with the airline shortly
thereafter, and was free to write what she
wanted, producing the story that would become
To Kill a Mockingbird.
But that wasn’t the end of the Browns’
generosity.
They were also able to put her in touch with
a literary agent, Maurice Crain, who would
later help Lee get her bestselling novel published.
Reportedly, the first draft read like several
short stories stitched together rather than
a seamlessly written novel.
Lee worked with editor Tay Hohoff to rework
the initial manuscript, and two and a half
years of rewrites followed.
She was warned that the book probably wouldn’t
sell more than few thousand copies.
However, Lee’s hard work had paid off more
than anyone could have expected.
Perhaps published at just the right time—dealing
with racial issues just as the civil rights
movement was kicking off in earnest—the
book’s popularity skyrocketed shortly after
publication in 1960.
It was picked up by the Book-of-the-Month
Club and the Literary Guild, featured in Reader’s
Digest, and won a variety of literary awards,
including the prestigious Pulitzer Prize.
By 1962, it had been made into an award-winning
movie.
Needless to say, Lee was doing quite well.
Over 30 million copies of the book have now
been sold, and it has been translated into
40 different languages.
In 2009, it was reported that Lee was still
earning $9,249 every day in royalties from
To Kill a Mockingbird.
At the moment, it’s estimated that Lee’s
estate is worth over $45 million, and it’s
estimated she’ll be earning $3-$4 million
every year until she dies—and likely as
long as the copyright lasts after her death,
too.
No word on if she paid back the Browns who
gave her the year’s wages that enabled her
to see such success.
As to why she wasn’t interested in continuing
to write and publish books after such a stunning
debut, she had this to say,
Two reasons: one, I wouldn’t go through
the pressure and publicity I went through
with To Kill a Mockingbird for any amount
of money.
Second, I have said what I wanted to say
and I will not say it again.